from screen jumping studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
booty fight now your host Andy signor
hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of movie fights I'm so excited
as an honor of Wonder Woman which was
fantastic
we are doing all DC movie fights this
week with questions such as which Batman
would win in a fight what is the best DC
movie of all time
who is the best overall character Batman
Superman or Wonder Woman it's a rematch
of our last one if we would win in a
fight now it's best character so much
fun stuff I'm so excited I have three
amazing DC experts let's meet them oh my
gosh look who's next to me it's right
over Wonder Woman 77 inch screen
druggies contributor for all things DC
mark and Renko welcome back your enemy
it's good to be back so happy to have
you I know you share my love of Wonder
Woman probably even more but I'm sure
we'll get into it during the fight but
yeah it's great to see that a great to
have you back I'm so happy to have this
person here next making her debut she's
the host of geek history lesson and
writer for DC Comics Ashley Robins and
welcome Ashley I'm so said it is finally
making on a movie file yes I'm sorry so
how you feeling your first fight you've
seen a show I imagine you prepped I'm
pretty nervous as the only woman here I
think I have the upper hand uh yeah that
could be Wonder Woman is in all our
thoughts right now and you got it um and
next up so happy to have him he was the
debut in the winner of the debut
deathmatch was so we are obligated to
bring you back no I'm viewers or seat
back he's the host of always stupid
answers podcast and you've seen them
here at SRI Nikki's news yup CJ
Woolridge welcome back man Gabriel oh
man so excited to talk everything see
see that's one of your expertise I love
it good then we all I love the way all
the shirt yes that skirt you skirt okay
that works near there go and including
this friend on the couch with Stan
Morelle will be fact-checking today's DC
show hey Dan hello how are you
okay a fat man and we got next to -
Michael oh Santa
here in line because they bumped into
Mike Carlson the carnies of the galaxy
ride I wrestle and ya couldn't make it
and you guys have what serendipitous
just the timing or cuz it looks great I
mean I'm Kentucky you can't we're very
excited to be here
how was the guardians of galaxy right he
was awesome it was really good much
better than our terror so not using the
line the cue and the music for the ride
just one side on videos who I heard this
is await golem volumes we just a
Fastpass but it was solid to our rate
wait the whole mountain with a fast pass
no this yeah but the Fast Pass was
twenty minutes
why here you missed the cue because Mike
waited and he got to see all the Easter
eggs goodwill having the queue in the
line me West Park Lao well the main
lobby I guess we went through that that
was cool
and then the whole Larry go we got check
this out talk about March anyway yeah
just goes you see alright welcome and
Dan you're here to fact-check sings you
guys know how this show works right any
questions before we begin
all right you want to get next
lovely night to time
that sounds like I missed that let them
fight I'm so glad it's back it's so
fancy now that new one is Mary Lee I'm
one of our fans ended up together round
did it loud if he did a great job all
right
round one this one is a big one we just
want to go start strong this is the
question what is the best DC Comics
movie adaptation now this has to be a
theatrical DC superhero film so lots to
pick from and Mark we're starting with
you what is your choice there's a lot to
choose from it was tough on the original
Superman is great Batman Returns as a
personal favorite I love Dark Knight but
I normally wouldn't go with a film that
is a new release but having after having
seen it three times I have to say Wonder
Woman Wonder Woman is one of those films
that like Dark Knight and like Logan
transcends the genre and unlike Batman
who's very open to interpretation and
their every interpretation of his valid
we have yet to see Wonder Woman come
together with all the different fences
over that work and all the different
permutations of her and penny Jenkins
and gal gadot make this character not
only the Wonder Woman movie I wanted to
see but far beyond any wonderful movie I
could have ever imagined it is um it's a
movie that is human and hopeful and I
think eminently watchable I've seen it
three times for free I'm going to go see
it tonight tomorrow and Saturday and I
entertain right hang yes you vote with
your dollars because this movie I put
this movie right up there with Raiders
of the Lost Ark in The Rocketeer and
this is a movie that that is going to be
as important as the original Superman
movie is important is the first x-men
movie this is a movie and historically
there's going to be great and it's a
great movie it's not a great comic book
movie it's a great great movie for
everyone every audience I've seen it
with every person I ask said I want to
see that again right now and it's it's
it's why I like loved the movies to see
a movie that is that fulfills every hope
I had and is even better than I could
hope Wow way to hype the movie forever -
it's a lot of that's very true alright
actually what are you picking I think
mark did a great job as an intro for me
because he dropped the Dark Knight a
bunch of times and for me there was no
choice besides the Dark Knight now it's
really easy to look at that and say it's
the first superhero movie that ever won
an Oscar for Best Actor I'm sort of
supporting actor and acting award for
Heath Ledger posthumously as the Joker
not only to keep redefine the Joker in
that role but the Dark Knight goes on to
redefine what we think of as a Best
Picture category at the Academy Awards
it went from five slots to ten slots
that open up the kind of movies that you
can consider their opening way for
things like bridesmaids different
comedies different animated movies to be
considered as well which means that
future movies hopefully like Wonder
Woman will be winning there as well and
I mentioned it redefines the Joker it
also redefines Batman in allowing our
first live-action Batman to turn his
head and see if he pulls out of the
driveway which is really really lovely
there is a ton of iconic lines
everything from somebody wants to watch
the Wilburn Wiseau series which the Hot
Topic kids god bless their souls geek
written on t-shirts - I'm not wearing
hockey pads which if you're Canadian is
a great line I'm really a big fan of
that it is relentless all of the sites
are on point it's really hard to poke
holes in this movie and it's one of the
only second movies in a superhero
franchise that doesn't drop the ball
Winter Soldier being another one and
it's not a typical origin the way a lot
of superhero movies are it extends who
this character is and it changes his
mythos in comic book movies all right TJ
who are you picking I like because my
you guys said theatrical my fate I think
the best adaptation of any superhero
character had a theatrical movie and
that is Batman mask of the phantasm
which is a film a continuation of the
classic Batman animated series which
includes the most iconic Batman and
Joker and Kevin Conroy is Batman and
Mark Hamill as the quintessential Joker
and like The Dark Knight does something
different with it it's not the same
origin although we do dive back into
what makes Batman Batman but export from
a new angle and also it does something
that is no other super movie has done a
good job with which is creating a new
villain that is iconic that adds to the
story and really dives into the
character in a way no other movie has
done sense and I think the DC Animated
universe is just the quintessential
version of that universe and this is
part of that all right find it out guys
we got Wonder Woman for mark Dark Knight
from Ashley maps for the phantasm from
DJ I think
Dark Knight is a historically important
movie for all the reasons you said
there's a big bud here and it's not just
mine is a Christian male from because I
like the player I thought early on as a
movie it is not a fully realized movie
there are brilliant parts in it but
there are parts in it could use an edit
and I love the movie I can watch Keith
ledger every day I think his performance
is transcendent but as a movie it
doesn't fit it's not a satisfying meal
there are parts the Harvey Dent stuff is
a little too long it drags in a couple
of places Christian Bale is not the most
interesting Batman the Farrakhan during
the movie the movie the movie Rises and
soars because of Heath Ledger and yes he
definitely deserved the Oscar and I'm a
firm believer that he would have won
that even if he hadn't died I think that
performances transcended but the
difference between Dark Knight which I
adore and Wonder Woman is Wonder Woman
doesn't have a teaser at the end like on
the Marvel movies it's a movie it's a
beginning middle and an end it's a full
meal it's part of this shared universe
but you don't make doesn't have to
earlier that's that's fine let me finish
you'll get your turn and and as a movie
Wonder Woman is there's the weakest part
of Wonder Woman is better than almost
anything in Dark Knight with the
exception of Heath Ledger you can walk
wonder when we can be shown to anyone
and everyone will be satisfied Dark
Knight has some has some rough spots in
it I say that as someone who loves Dark
Knight going back to Kumasi phantasm I
love Batman the Animated Series I'm in
college would skip classes and have my
VCR and dub out commercials while taping
it on videotape mask of phantasm note to
me when I watch it made me want to watch
episodes of the show I think there are
some once again great some good things
about masculine TASM but I think if
you're looking at these as movie
experiences the two hours are spending
or two and a half hours with that man I
think Wonder Woman is the one that is
the most complete meal that serves every
master correctly is it too early to call
that with one more I mean I'm not a
cable but having a little unfair to be
arguing for a movie that DJ hasn't seen
yeah not real why Mel honestly I hope
you're absolutely right because I'm
seeing I'm glad I'm leading straight
from here to go see it I hope you're
absolutely right
I love the Dark Knight but it's not it's
not the best Batman you give me a single
bit of a line I don't know masks in the
fan
the line makes best adaptation I think a
medium that it was originally employed I
think I think that available
distillation of the character I think
the most the closest you ever get to the
comic book Batman on the big screen is
Kevin Connors Batman in mask of the
phantasm and I also think it does some
of the most interesting things with the
character with exploring the one moment
he had where he decided whether he was
going to be Batman or not we don't go
back to his parents time we go to that
moment right before we flash back to the
moment right before he becomes Batman
and has an opportunity to have true love
how many times have we had a romance
works like Batman she's hampered by the
fact that he's living in a romance novel
with a joker fight at the end I mean the
phantasm isn't even the main villain of
that story it's the Joker who again
transcends and is redefined in the Dark
Knight in videos you could argue that
about Batman The Dark Knight who was the
main villain you've got the Joker then
you've got Harvey Dent then you've got
you've got the the Chinese gangsters as
well again there's only really about the
Scarecrow shows up there's so much stuff
in that that once again I think this is
this is a Sophie's Choice to an extent
because all three of these movies are
really really good but I think as a
movie experience which is what is the
best film Wonder Woman and I and I
normally wouldn't I've seen it three
times over the past three weeks I've
gotten I every time I talk about it I
get emotional I had goosebumps and I
haven't felt this way about a moving in
a very very very long enough overselling
man you know what I'm not I'm not I
firmly believe I'm not because when I
talk about it it makes me want to go see
the movie again actually you've seen it
right I have seen in high overselling it
he's not overselling it but I would say
that it's difficult to contend about
whether a movie that's not yet hit its
large theatrical release is going to be
the best of all time of a franchisor of
a genre because we haven't seen the
cultural impact that it's going to have
yes I guess we absolutely have already
it's already do but the opening weekend
projections two weeks ago were 50 and
now it's probably going to break over a
million what it makes yes but but you
talk about the people you talk about
every audience I've seen this with every
single woman I've seen this with his has
had tears in their eyes saying this
movie is unlike any movie I've ever seen
this movie is already in its it's not
even out yet but the advanced screenings
and the places that have seen it has
changed moviemaking
it is it is it all right you've sold me
again and it's hard for him to argue
that's what you need I need to hear more
why those two aren't right and
again what even without seeing it you're
making a strong argument that you have
it's too early so it gave me some more
against the others and your final
thoughts here well I think the again the
Dark Knight the strongest element is not
the Batman it is it is Joker and it is a
redefinition of it and it's not
necessarily the most accessible take on
the dark night the the a for a
distillation of Batman that anybody can
see anybody can connect to and almost
universally this Batman is praised as
the Batman and for H before a cartoon to
get its own movie I also think it's one
of the not only is Batman anime series
one of the best adaptations that movie
is the best extension of a cartoon to
the big screen that no matter what age
you are young old or whatever you can
watch and understand what makes Batman
taken to seeing you sides to them and
see you decide to the Joker because he
connects to Batman's past in an
interesting way and on this ham-fisted
way then the Tim Burton Batman I think
it's difficult to argue that as a
vestige for lease because it didn't
receive wide sea at release it was
minimum it was only in large cities most
people saw it either on television a lot
lighter so reiterated serious
well it didn't even make it to my
country so I clearly didn't get that
line I saw I saw it in theaters and and
it is to this day one of the best demos
the people respond by the action figures
because a lot might but not the action
figure that had her head and it's
actually it's action scenes are better
than the Dark Knight because fist fights
are not work for super Nolan shines
knows a lot of them major thing is the
movie that gives us the tumbler which is
still to this day many people say with
Batmobile I haven't never heard anyone
say that about the Batmobile in the back
goes which one of these two movies has a
Batmobile on the Warner Brothers tour
well I mean which world and we action
figured the Batmobile has sold more
probably and we're diverting from the
actual question which which is the best
film adaptation of these characters and
as you said that Batman mess of the
phantasm is an utterly accessible one
even if you only briefly know who Batman
is that's exactly the same argument I'm
using for Wonder Woman Wonder Woman can
be shown to anyone even if you don't
know the comic books and you will have a
deeply fully satisfying experience that
being said I love The Dark Knight but as
a as a movie experience there are there
are some big gaps there are some dull
spots there are some flat spots and
actually not a Dark Knight movie it's a
joker moving it is a movie that remains
to date the best-selling and the most
celebrated of the three options it's a
really good movie yeah it's a really
good climber Detective Comics alright
aren't enough and Merle handing a clean
up there fact-checking wise I mean as
you would expect from a panel of DC
experts pretty clean round fact wise
marks did talk about the tracking on
wonderful in which if you're watching on
YouTube on Saturday you're in the future
and you know if you're accurate but
right now yes the tracking was upgraded
from 55 to 60 now to around 95 million
dollars but again tracking has been
notoriously hard unpredictable so it's
gonna say I'm saying from the past I'm
going to break it on a plane that I'm
happy to make that bet - yeah but bark
was corrected the tracking on Monroe but
has it upgraded in the last week since
the reviews have come out that was
pretty much the only factual thing that
I thought needed some clearing up yeah
me I'll be honest I thought dg8 seen it
so with a little unfair for DJ not to
that but then I was hoping that they
would just do some fake news or
something and debate based on I think
Paul will omit there was maybe the
villain and little mich is not very good
I'm sorry
Ares really looks nice it was a little
bit so I will acknowledge I was a little
unfair and I'm sorry I didn't catch that
sooner but that aside based on the rest
of the arguments I do think I do think I
got to go with just based on the passion
from mark hoot and the time and the
punch punches back I just heard a little
bit he just over talked you guys a
little bit I think was the oh I love
this because I love them now I know I
think in the first round jitters maybe
have you guys going against a Titan here
and if I heard a little bit more from
him so that's where I'm leaning there
and so I think going in I want you guys
to play harder but also I just got a too
many specifics of the turning of the
head and stuff didn't feel like the the
biggest of arguments that could have
probably been said for Dark Knight says
and in Masson phantasm yeah he sort of
got you is there are better episodes of
the show so those sort of things knocked
out so mark is the first point but it's
not over let's go to round two
alright now this one's going to be a
doozy
okay that's a full show our cards we ask
this question to see if you guys would
pick your own each ones they don't want
someone have to focus ekend choice and
you each picked your first choice and
that's pretty cool I want to have it
clear that's why this is in the show
because I don't want to make one of you
fight one that you didn't believe in so
here's the question this is like a
reform outfit I thought no no you all
this your own number one and what's
interesting is markets fought this
battle before and you make wonder one
before I'm going to because they can
check out there's a wonder woman in the
fight yes your and I'm going to say it
out loud I'll set it all up we're going
best overall character Batman versus
Superman versus went over now
best overall character it's a little
vague so you got to tell me what makes
the best character why is it Batman
Superman Wonder would let's just go down
the line you're picking a Wonder Woman
you're picking a lot of Batman Batman so
marks got Batman Ashley your Wonder
Woman I'm going to side mark for though
and DJ you pick Superman yep
okay well as you get to start that's
want to make sure we all know who is
playing for who the Wonder Woman for
Ashley DJ is picking Superman mark it's
big Batman actually whenever you ready
so Wonder Woman is not only the coolest
kid in school right now but as the DCE
you stand she's the only character that
everybody consistently likes everybody
likes for casting everyone who's seen
the movie loves to perform if you heard
mark talking about how great that movie
is just a couple minutes ago even in the
comic book she brings a bit of diversity
to the Justice League
she's the only lgbtqia+ character which
I think definitely deserves some
recognition that's something that could
potentially be explored and is very
exciting about the way the cinematic
universe is going she's the least
bloodthirsty of any of these characters
on or off the page she stands for love
she stands for peace yes she can rip
your head off if she wants to but her
rule is typically to try to show people
or the animals that she can talk to
because she has a lot of really cool
familiars you even Disney Princess to
show them how they can better themselves
by the strength that they carry that is
something that is uniquely feminine and
that is a strength that her that not a
lot of the other DC heroes in any
incarnation have plus she's the sexiest
she has the best costumes and the best
legs and in a world where we're watching
movies that are incredibly visually
driven
that can't count for nothing so what a
woman definitely the best all right well
that's right
well here more Superman DJ go ahead
Superman is the definitive superhero
he's the one if you had a favorite
superhero you can thank Superman for
that super hero existing he is the one
that took pulp heroes into the Super
Hero generation he's the one he's the
reason Batman exists he's the reason
Wonder Woman exists spider-man any and
all of them
he's also other three I honestly believe
be most well-rounded because he Clark
Kent is such a big part of his mythos
and it really humanizes him and his
dedication to wanting to be a person and
understand how real people is Bruce
Wayne some brooding millionaire when
he's not Batman so it's always kind of
the same and then Diana Prince is always
underplayed with Wonder Woman it doesn't
factor in very much I don't know about
the new movie but doesn't really factor
into her character where there's an
everyman quality that I think people
underestimate with Superman and makes
him incredibly relatable and you've got
to remember one woman does add diversity
but Superman's origin is created by two
poor Jewish kids this Canadian but
wanted to that that that wanted to
create a hero that stood up for
everything they wanted to stand up for
defend them when they were not defended
for and that ideology is what inspired
characters like Wonder Woman to say hey
we should have a female version of this
of course we should because people
everybody wants to feel defended that's
what superheroes represent that's what
Superman represents right about mark
well that man before I dive into Batman
I do want to say there's a reason why
these characters are a threat to is the
Trinity because they're all three great
transcended characters and I agree with
both of the things you said about your
characters but the difference between
bat and Superman was the first Wonder
Woman was the first woman Batman is the
rare care the character in almost any
genre fiction that can be reinterpreted
in almost any different time frame and
different way and it works
The Brave and the bold cartoon show the
Adam West Batman The Dark Knight movies
the Tim Burton movies the Christian Bale
movies the the comic books they're the
Frank Miller versions you know in bed
they've done Batman Elseworlds where he
fought Jack the Ripper they've done
Batman in the future his character
there's something primal about his
origin that he can be readapted in so
many different ways Superman is always
the Big Blue Boy Scout and I don't mean
that
demeaning way Wonder Woman is the Greek
goddess Batman your son can watch Batman
the Animated Series or brave on the ball
cartoons now and we the teenager he can
watch The Dark Knight and then you can
watch a Justice League movie or the
Gotham TV show and all of those
different permutations are violent but
they remain faithful to the core of the
character and to have a character in
fiction who can be transported into any
time frame any sort of genre any sort of
story and still remain faithful to the
core of that character and I will argue
that Batman's costume is a much better
costume than Wonder Woman the
iconography of Batman you're too young
probably to remember how crazy in 1989
was when the Batman now I know that's
horrifying
in 1989 before we you know we for we
said we were so spoiled now by the
inundation of all the superhero stuff
Batman there was just a poster of the
logo and every person bought t-shirts
because of the word they responded to
that iconography I worked in a movie
theater in high school we had people buy
tickets to movies that were showing the
trailer to Batman and they would leave
after they showed the trailer this was
pre-internet yes I'm that old
Batman is Batman is somehow a character
that can adapt to the whatever the time
period is whatever is involved in the
world and the political scene and the
personal scene and whatever is going on
the pop culture the pop art of the 60s
of Batman TV show is hilarious but still
faithful to the core and there's no
character that I can think of in any
fiction that is that versatile and that
adaptable and that transcendent as
Batman that being said it's a game of
inches here but I think that man that
facet of him alone that there are as
many different versions of Batman as
there are people and I think that's
something I open up the floor so I would
just argue that Wonder Woman is not who
we are in the way that Batman is who
every angry 16 year old wants to be and
Superman is who every farmer from Kansas
wants to be and then I love a farmer
from Kansas don't get me wrong but
Wonder Woman is who we should strive to
be she is a goddess she is above us she
is the best in all of us and she is what
we should strive to be because she came
down from basically what is having not
done yet
if you're going to argue but she's a
female version of Superman she's not
that is called Supergirl and
the characters stuck in the 1940s we'll
never transcend being a farmer in Kansas
yes I didn't know that Kansas backs
showed up in the 70s on the radio show
but he is a product of the 20th century
he doesn't transcend into 21st century
storytelling which is why there are so
many people who will show up to you when
you work at a comic book store and tell
you that they don't like him now more
than ever people are showing up for a
Wonder Woman they're fighting for which
of her best runs are all being rebranded
which is phenomenal and Diana Prince has
been a working professional for her
entire life she's been a spy she's been
a secret agent she's been museum curator
she's been an ambassador to the UN and
tiny little spoiler but not really in
the wonderful movie she does have a job
so the Diana Prince persona is a working
professional in the modern world as all
women have to be those are jobs
Clark Kent is how Superman has perceived
himself and how he connects to the human
condition Batman doesn't connect with
the human condition when he goes home
she's a billionaire playboy like I don't
relate to that I've never related to
management alien from 5,000 light years
I wanted to a guy that needs to make
rent and wants to make a world a better
place and is actively trying to be done
to make language I read free play my
brother he has to fly we have to pay
rent
he works for one of the giant media
corporations in the world that doesn't
mean what even to work anyway who makes
a very nice Joe here time just fired a
bunch of people so so but you see
doesn't take part where he doesn't he
doesn't train send to the 21st century
people still buy Superman comics
Superman comics are selling better than
ever in fact his ideals transcend into
every superhero ever created and the
people the problem is that people don't
they try to add stuff to him when the
core is so strong Batman is super is is
uh what was the term you use can he can
he could can permute eight and a lot of
different ways but there's something so
profound about a character that that
doesn't need to fit his core is so
strong I didn't say that may need it to
be adapted there's something there's
something there's some weird alchemy
about the Batman character that allows
him to adapt to different stories
whether it's the Lego Batman or the
Christopher Nolan Batman they're all
valid they're all valid extensions of
the original story that Bill Finger with
Bob Kane created
nice phrasing and implements the correct
reason and and I love all three of these
characters these characters are to us
what Greek mythology was to the ancient
Greeks and the Romanovs ology these
characters are all trans they all get
word we all have jobs because these
characters exist and that's very
important to say this isn't this isn't I
don't want to slam either one of these
two other two characters because I love
them dearly but there's something about
Batman just look at all the different
versions of Batman that are out there
and there's one for every single person
and that's something that's that can't
be said welcome I have two problem of
being a female character and there's a
lack of adaptation for her so I think
it's a little tough to say that Batman I
mean he does he has the most adaptations
he has the most versions comics TV
movies whatever but when you're a female
character and who's been portrays a
character of color for a long time those
are characters that people want to make
media about and the fact that she's
finally transcending she's only really
been portrayed as a character of color
she was a white woman on a Greek island
she's only recently the cancelling of
gal gadot is very powerful because of
that because she has actually a woman
who looks like she's from somewhere in
the Mediterranean so the argument that
she's a woman of color and a gay woman
or a bisexual women bearing on their own
recent and I don't that doesn't mean
it's not valid but once again the best
overall character everybody has
everybody has their own Batman that they
love people love these two characters
right guys one version I want to hear
more than that give me you've hit that
point cray but I need I need more from
that yeah go ahead against each other
Wonder Woman Superman I one woman is
very important but I think part of what
allows her gives her the space to be
that important is like you're saying
this character is created by two
immigrants so that and that's the power
of the superhero genre is that you get
to that's why diversity and super
energon are so important because you get
to project yourself into these
characters that are larger than life and
helps you overcome your issues that
started with Superman and it's an idea
that's so powerful that it not only
launched a million different types of
characters but it has lasted to this day
that Superman Centreville assemble you
could go anywhere in the world and they
will know what that means and they will
know what that represents
and it's an ideology that just stays as
great as Batman one or more they just
can't compete with Wonder Woman was
created by polyamorous scientists which
is pretty impressive
yes in the 1940s so I don't think that
that should be discounted at all I would
also argue that Wonder Woman in compared
to Superman has more iconography as far
as her weaponry yes we know Superman for
his powers but Wonder Woman is a well
trained character she earned her power
and the lasso appeared to something that
is singular to her and that represents
her maybe it's not as I could I can a
graphic as the shield with the s inside
of it because it's not the house of L
sign it's a shield just like Lois's
maybe s and s and I think that that is
also worthy of her legacy that she has
weapons that we noted to find her by and
the movie is going to give her another
one well listen i grant Batman because
if his his all his toys they will sell a
lot of action figures and one will
probably be able to sell a lot of action
figures but I think there somebody said
by Superman not needing weapons and not
needing that to be part of his identity
I would say Batman is obviously
incredibly popular one woman is gaining
a popular and very important but I think
overall if you take the whole package
Superman not only has the popular he has
the importance about not just the
immigrant story but about what heroism
represents he's also the quintessential
superhero that all others sprang spring
from an apartment that is not just his
powers in this age of superheroes we're
losing the importance of the secret
identity because that's the part that we
connect to and of the three of them the
secret identity the part that connects
the character to the people Clark can
even be most important to Superman and I
think what part of what makes him so
important as opposed to equally great
characters like Batman and one of them
all right Dan what do you think here
based on those arguments to the socks
facts well is just actually a couple
things DJ brought up the Superman
Superman sales figures I was trying to
find the latest sales it looks like
currently and and it looks to be a bit
of a trend Batman is easily DC's
best-selling a character right now as of
April flash also up there a Superman is
actually a little bit kind of in the
middle of the pack with Wonder Woman so
if we're going sales figures Batman is
actually kind of leading the DC sales at
the current time just a little piece of
trivia that I've picked up William
Moulton Marston who was the creator of
Wonder Woman also invented a key
component of what
knows the modern polygraph DJ yeah the
lasso of truth and the it wasn't always
a loss of tree that used to make you
submit to Wonder Woman's orders the the
truth part is a 19-hour computer out of
silver agent well that's what I get for
trying to bring up Joanna may be good to
other that's what I get for starting to
be of trivia energy look like I'm
obviously out of my own so never mind
strike it from the record know what your
wonderful mansplaining now that's about
time
alright some it isn't has bacon Wonder
Woman Michael standard what you think
based on those arguments I need help
here arguments I got I got one I think
I'm leaning on but I was originally in
Wonder Woman's corner but then DJ
brought up the s beats out the Batman
shield and that it's international so
I'm gonna go DJ on this one yeah there
was something awesome that's where I'm
leaning to there was the amount that you
look these are all three great
characters all important characters
Wonder Woman's pecet especially right
now and probably unfairly but yeah it's
like she now is when the the Wonder
Woman heat is starting to grow which is
great for all of us to that to happen
but it's still like there was something
about Superman and the arguments that I
heard from DJ of just about the human
condition and the ideology we stand for
to define the superhero the secret
identity was another good point you
brought in as well there was and just a
you can't he his argument back to you
about Batman will can be around but
soumarin always remains the same to his
core all those things really rang true
for me that just a little bit edge over
although I was very close because I'm
sure Supergirl knock it back at him with
brilliant and she does up a spine
working agent thing there as well but if
there's a slight edge to Superman so
gonna give DJ the point
it's not over here we go all right guys
now we've been so positive you gotta go
little mean they haven't all been great
this one came in from irh at 2001 on
Twitter they want to know what's the
worst DC movie all DC movies not DC EU
we're not sticking on them any worse
there are a lot of there are a lot of
stickers in this category if you go back
to the years some I forgot about I will
see if you guys picked them DJ what are
you picking worse DJ the worse than TJ
Batman Robin okay looks like we just do
the last one go round mark Superman 300k
Ashley Supergirl I'll have movies
Superman 3 and Supergirl
okay back to you DJ uh listen oh wait
what's that say very cheeky ah trick
question what's the actual question
what's the best DC movie that's right
you have to use your answers and tell us
why it's the best DC movie killer timing
holographics know now really that's
really the best question the best movie
this is we don't want to be negative
here we want to be positive here so now
DJ you must tell me why Batman and Robin
is the best DC movie even better than
mask of the phantasm actually you guys
put me quite supergirls better than
wonderful I'm one who is our Dark Knight
brother and Mark white Superman 3 better
than Wonder Woman let's hear this for
real this is this problem out is now for
those of you haven't played a trick
question before you have to sell it if
you try and cheat out here and don't
tell me that your book is the best you
will lose points goodbye everyone
I understand this work this was a fan
request hi DJ you're at first is Fran's
name market above this one DJ all right
we're going now a best PC movie they had
to pick the worst but now they have to
tell that's the best DJ Batman Robin why
is it the best Lucent DC movies get a
lot of crap now for not being called
Batman Robin does not have that problem
all right you got all mean um but I was
really kids love it all the highlights
and if I'm being honest listen the Tim
Burton movies as a child and the
theaters scared me I'm still traumatized
by penguin bite not that guys knows you
got none of that in Batman and Robin
you got fun campy takes on Mr Freeze
with Arnold Schwarzenegger and poison
ivy and everybody's favorite Bane first
time he's on the big screen and and it's
it's we don't get enough of Batman and
Robin interacting on the big screen
other than maybe the rubber nipples that
Robin costumes really cool pre-staged
the Nightwing costume redesign which is
very cool Chris O'Donnell saw her only
on screen Robin and the Irate is that a
good thing and also beta oh yeah you
know what he's a lot of fun I like I
like him a lot in Batman Forever it just
continues being himself and Batman and
Robin and continue and also and so my
colleague Mark said Batman is such a
versatile character and he can make
almost anything work and and this is a
great exhibit Illiana durability of the
Batman you don't know there is never a
moment when we come back I do want to
know why is it better than mask of the
phantasm mark Superman 3 Superman 3 was
the first superhero trilogy and we're
talking about reliving of age-related
diversity and the co-lead of the movie
was Richard Pryor great witch back in
the time when that came out having
having a black adult comedian and a
franchise for families was great in the
classic Superman comic super in a
splitted astray by red slip around blue
and that
a great scene in the harbor and the
garbage dump was happening at planting
Clark Kent that harkens back to the
classic wrote for one book to the 50s
the no smoking message the nicotine the
kryptonite it was a great thing for kids
to prevent them from smoking how many
kids don't have emphysema or lung cancer
because of Superman 3 you have the
opening sequence which is like the
opening of pee-wee's big adventure is
that Rube Goldberg thing where things
happen and fall it's great brilliant
physical comedy the check would be proud
of where's the vodka and introduces Lana
Lana Lang for the first time on the
screen and I know - it was so great
movie the nominee she's the only
character to play two members of
Superman Shama she played his girlfriend
in the Superman Chris Reeve franchise
initially when he played in Martha Kent
in Smallville so all superhero movies
spring from Superman 3 again will come
back and I want to hear why it's better
than Wonder Woman ashle Supergirl all
female superhero movies spring from
Supergirl it's the first one that we got
and you know what Helen Slater stars as
Supergirl you can see her she's
beautiful she's are so good but she's
still an important part of the Supergirl
meet those to this day she is currently
playing a Liza danver - super girls mom
she handed off the torch to Melissa
Benoist she heralded into this great TV
show because we wouldn't have the TV
show if that movie weren't as amazing as
it is if you haven't seen it she does
some tremendous hand acting while she's
flying that really makes Supergirl
flight powered elegant in comparison to
what we've seen from Superman in his
hard-edged and Marx favorite superhero
franchise of all time
this also carries on the legacy that
Christopher Reeve sat down in those
movies without needing him were not
bogged down by a male character showing
up instead of letting the female
superhero do her job Supergirl doesn't
need any help from Christopher Reeve
Helen Slater has it completely under
control she even gets a scene with Peter
O'Toole and goes toe to toe with him
while they're flying on their way to
earth
this also introduces Lucy Lane who's an
important part of the current Supergirl
nito's appearing in the first season of
that shows the first time that we saw
her who's Lois's little sister and the
costume looks great it's probably the
best super old costume that we've ever
seen and I completely don't hate this
movie
all right guys let's go back DJ why is
it better than a festive Pantha I feel
like I'm completely bizarre world like I
want to like key points to help like now
we're helping each other and run it
together we could enjoy something
different yeah this is what you want
both of the kids to be sitting backwards
Batman and Robin has Robin and he's not
matter because it has more village it
has more villains and it has tremendous
actor actress Uma Thurman this was
George Clooney's one shot at being
Batman great and
an A for diversity he said he played
Batman as gay in this movie so there's
that well the Joel Schumacher film duh
no I sold our I toy it sold so many
times mad and ok Mark Weiss ran three
better than Wonder Woman well uh-huh um
this is really hard um I wasn't prepared
to it's better than Wonder Woman because
it came out before Wonder Woman went
today
The Wonder Woman to improve upon the
door did Superman three opened and
allowed Wonder Woman to say oh this is
what you did well and I'm going to
improve upon the brilliant things you
did and make them even more brilliant we
had we had Christopher Reeve playing
multiple characters in this movie he
played Superman II played Clark Kent he
played Clark Kent around Lois he played
nicotine Clark Kent
and he played angry subway Superman in
the dirty gray suit that's five
characters
that's duck you know that's like Meryl
Streep can't do that gal gadot playing
one yeah yeah I mean it's crazy and and
once again in this day and age of you
know nutrition and and health issues it
had a such a poignant no smoking message
in it as I'm making a superman show that
nicotine even as bad for Superman so at
this movie this movie has saved lives
that's ultimately something I go back
around before we all do the pre-pro
Ashley why super go better than Dark
Knight Super Bowl is better than the
Dark Knight because it actually has some
color in it it's not just a sepia tone
movie which is really lovely most of it
takes place during the day with the
added bonus of being largely set in a
girl school so you get to see a lot of
cute twice on the girls running around
in their little Catholic schoolgirls you
or much I'm sure informed many men about
their respective sexualities I saw
online
there's only informed me on my sexuality
fights a witch no magic anywhere in the
dark night I mean way better than Heath
Ledger's Joker all right
you guys are playing Marvin I appreciate
it now and yeah now how do you help you
pay for if you listen why sort of the
better why is you're the best if we're
talking about colorful movies but I see
Batman Robin is the most colorful it has
the most colors how many of these movies
and has me on the other movies do not
have that also message steroids are bad
if you take stars you'll be like blame
of bein a misery idiot with fake arms
and that's a with green veins it's just
not good
also more iconic villains point IV
mister free reign a Woodrum guys there
for a minute
is Batman Robin better the worst
I'm confused with you yeah why which was
the best here you can answer e better
even never girl because Supergirl is the
one of these three that I've seen one of
these that I haven't seen oh yeah three
horrible horrible movies mine was the
first I'm very glad to each chose to
command 3 instead of 4 because 3 is
better than Superman for all that has an
angry drunk in it anyway listen
so also Batman Robin - Batgirl we forgot
first on screen and only live-action
background without any other way the
cowl is Silverstone his bad girl she's
also blog which is incorrect
ok and Albert's goddaughter which makes
zero sense
yeah wait and maybe they have to see
Alfred which we get provides personal
stakes alright again I'm just doing that
one last final suffrage you know you got
to tell me mark Wyatt Superman 3 better
than Supergirl about Nana Robin quickly
good because it expands the mythos when
it opens up and almost again we're
talking about colorfulness I mean the
diversity that the risk of taking a
fairly white middle-class superhero on
putting an edgy black comedian in it and
committing to that it was a big deal to
time alright actually by a super girl
better than Ben in Rob
three again it's the one I've seen it
has a female lead and it builds on
everything that the Christopher Reeve
Branch I sat down which was incredibly
important making this even more
important all right DJ you serve already
did that right there Dan mm-hmm how you
doing over there anything to add that's
hard to add to because there's one small
correction to Mark's argument while it
does not weaken the anti-smoking message
of Superman three it was actually a Tarr
not nicotine that was the corrupting
ingredient in the Kryptonite in Superman
three still a component of the
cigarettes are still talking yes exactly
so it doesn't change marks argument
fundamentally just a change of
ingredient it was the guitar all right
fair enough
that's the best we could come up I got
to give you all props you really tried
but I there was one that I thought
trialed the hardest and that was GJ I
got a little bit more positivity from DJ
there's a lot in them yeah you really
sold me and then you're even mark you
stuttered a few times Ashley I guess
just didn't see the other films it was
hard for you like and I have a good
thing for you so you really win this
round always extra of your life we
actually really win but DJ gets the
point all right number four here we go
this comes in from Bad wit user names on
Twitter he wants to know what DC comic
storyline that hasn't already been used
would make the best movie and I think
it's coming up on screen there it is no
that's not correct new switching we're
going to go to that little switch here
we go
values names a lover of films you want
to know this yes and you also can choose
a director so what DC storyline do you
want to see that we haven't seen as a
movie mark we're back to you
yeah I chose Grant Morrison's Arkham
Asylum
and to be directed by David Fincher
because what's great about Arkham Asylum
is it's Batman being locked in the
asylum so you get to use every single
one of his marquee villains and it's
also like Batman meets the raid it's
this enclosed space where Batman has to
adapt to being in this Asylum and
features got such a dark rich visual
style that having that seven look in a
Batman movie set it's basically a
haunted house story the graphic novel
and Fincher gets that too weird
psychosexual parts of it and
and it can also do the great visuals and
create mood and it's important that if
you've read Grant Morrison's graphic
novel that he did with David McKean
Arkham Asylum is not just a location
it's a character and if you watch every
David Fincher movie every location feel
that it's a living breathing part of a
movie and this would be and he would
elevate the material to have a director
on our tour like David Fincher come in
to do a Batman movie would be great and
to see him have this has every marquee
character every villain is in this
building so you get everything that's
quite great about that mad Ashley so I
picked Batman under the Red Hood which
was adapted to an animated movie but if
we're playing by the rules from our
first question and DJ cosmic mask of the
phantasm this one did not get a wipe the
at release it was just really
straight-to-dvd under the Red Hood for
those who don't know is the return of
Jason Todd where we he's brought back
from the dead for the first time who was
the second Robin who was brutally
murdered by the Joker so it's a great
way to incorporate the Joker who's
already a part of the standard DC EU
universe Jason Todd Robin exists already
in the current DC EU we've seen the
Robin suit we've seen his boots we've
seen the bullet holes in their WB
torogai confirmed that that is Jason
Todd sue to saw Tim Drake's not too gray
since nobody else it is Jason Todd and
in a Suicide Squad movie it confirms
when you meet Harley Quinn for the first
time that she is a murderer of Robin an
accomplice along with the Joker so you
have all the groundwork laid for this to
exist it tells you more about Batman and
it is a true detective story which is
run with a lot of the Batman movies that
we've seen we don't see of doing any
detecting we see heist movie like DJ
talked about we see horror movie
elements like Mark talked about this
would give you a chance to legitimize
Robin who is incredibly important part
of the DC myth of tell the detective
story and introduce characters like
Nightwing and Barbara Gordon Batgirl or
Oracle if you want to go that way that
we know there are already slots for and
movies for in development plus it's the
animated movie is well liked and Batman
Arkham Knight which is one of the
best-selling DC video games of all time
is based on this story which means
there's already an audience who wants to
see this writ large alright DJ I choose
the Brainiac storyline by Geoff Johns
and Gary Frank because we've had I think
like eight or nine Superman films and we
have not gotten one of his maybe
arguably his
iconic villain which is Brainiac and
Brainiac it would be great to see on
film for a variety of reasons not only
the incredibly cinematic but he also
adds an interesting layer to a Superman
story that we haven't gotten before
because Brainiac is a very alien villain
and so this gives us an opportunity to
explore the man part of Super Man which
is fan as a fan of the characters the
part that matters to us fans the most
and have a chance for we've had a lot of
superhero movies where they're like oh I
don't know should I stop being a hero
this could be a movie where he explores
why he decides to be Clark Kent what
Clark Kent means to him while he's
facing a larger-than-life villain that
forces him to think as opposed to punch
his way out of a situation like he did
with Zod or like he did with doomsday
and Superman is always great when he has
to think his way out of situation cuz
he's very smart it's also a story that
included Supergirl so it would add some
diversity to the Superman mythos we can
incorporate Supergirl and to figure out
how to stop Brainiac elements of that
story also used in a very popular
injustice to game and I would choose a
ryan coogler to direct this movie
because he's proven with his movies that
he's so good with cream and fruit gas
station that he's very good at finding
the human relatable elements to a
character which I think would really
help Superman right now and while we
have we've had a lot of very successful
Batman movies that have explored a lot
of his villains with this we would get
it to explores new villains new sides of
Superman
new storytelling opportunities that I
think would be really are really good
for the DCU right now did you pick a
director I did and I forgot to mention I
picked my fellow Canadian David
Cronenberg because as we've seen with
things like history of violence and
Eastern Promises he does a great job at
balancing out emotional beast with great
wonderful choreographed fights and stark
violence which is what you need in
something like this and then there's a
good chance that Viggo Mortensen is
going to be cast in it and I'm always
down for that right Jason fun as whoever
you want I've taken miss Jason Todd fine
alright find it out guys we get we've
had a bunch of Batman movies like I love
Arkham Asylum but we've seen a majority
of those villains already in movies and
I think the elements that make that
comic special could not would not be
adapted into a feature even by David
Fincher the other problem with both
Fincher and Cronenberg is the movies you
catch will be very are
be very very are have you seen the DCU
movies did you say she Wiggin don't they
they didn't hold it yeah but Jane they
do it and they're good but Batman is not
a character that you can tell our story
with him I would argue that that is not
the character at his best I think I
think Logan benefit bullring benefits
from that difficult can benefit from
that I don't know if Batman does and I
don't know if he's called the Dark
Knight but would those movies be better
than any of the ones that we've already
gotten that wasn't the question what the
question was what do you what on what DC
Comics story language like to see
adapted to a film with the director and
so would make the best movie when you've
picked a story where the cornerstone
emotional moment of it is pas can't
dying he's already dead in the current
DC EU universe and people didn't like it
very much when that happened so why
would you want to do that and then
essentially make it a redux of Man of
Steel which I love but it's
controversial because it's a villain
coming down from the sky Superman fights
them you know it's not straying far
enough or building on the meat sauce
that's already set down and you said
about Ryan Coogler is the director yeah
Ryan Coogler is great with human stuff
but you have a movie with the villain is
and is an alien entity a with no human
emotion whatsoever so that's not going
to play to his strengths and it's going
to be a super expensive movie these are
all pretty pricey movies but your
particular making Brainiac comes to life
is a lot of money and I don't know if a
studio would give Ryan Coogler two
hundred and fifty million dollars to
make this movie and you're inviting the
controversy of having to recast a very
popular TV character middle of a noise
Supergirl is very well loved people hate
that they recast Flash and that it's not
going to be Grant Gustin so I don't know
if that's a door that you want to open
casting another girl to place to propose
a lot of flexibility in the story and
all these movies are mixed tapes with
they're not straight adaptions because
straight adaptions wouldn't work I mean
in your version Jason Todd was shot and
and uh instead of being beat where the
crowbar looks like he was shot and we
don't know shoots the money I beat them
with a crowbar yeah and today he knows
that
also also I argued a centaur was way
better dead Jason talk should stay dead
I think he adds more to the Batman
mythos dead in Red Hood is way better as
a villain he's one of that his greatest
contemporary Island does the bringing
storyline add elements that the DCU does
not already have add stuff to Superman
that we've never seen on film before I
think it would it diversifies the type
of storytelling the DC could do whereas
your movies are more Batman movies and
more people like that man that I they do
but we they've had the question like my
family and also as they fit into the DC
extended universe this question was what
would make the best movie and this I
believe Arkham Asylum of all three of
these stories is a story that doesn't
need great exposition and great
explanation it's Batman getting lost in
the asylum with all of his foes and he
asked and he can't escape your movie I
would love to see the Jason ton story
explored but it's one also comes from
one of the darkest most cynical events
in comics was the one 900 number vote
whether Jason Todd lived or died which
is just nuts pans to wasn't that kind of
like rigged by a fan or something like
just redial we die we dial and whether
it was it happened but it also brings
back to the Jason Choi comes back from
the dead it brings magic into the Batman
universe and they brought racial drool
Nolan brought him in and he ignored the
Lazarus Pit thing bringing magic into
the Batman universe Batman is a core
isn't cinematically at least grounded in
a some reality even with the gadgets you
bring magic into it and it kind of up
ends the apple tart a little and makes
it and there's a lot of deep cuts in the
history of your story you need to
there's so much explanation of before we
get to the Red Hood how he got there how
he's a second Robin and how he died and
how he came back then I don't know how
accessible that is you're gonna have a
movie that is the first 2/3 are going to
be explaining to the audience what
they're about to signing I would I would
also argue with your pick for Arkham
Asylum that's a very cerebral movie
you're asking a lot of your consumers
asking a lot of your audience and I
don't know if we live in a world where
cerebral it's the raid with Batman on
his villains it's Batman fighting his
way out of all these crazy people in
thank you and question it's a
psychological exploration of this
character that I don't know if people
are ready for and because people find a
graphic novel challenging in a world
where people think that Deadpool is the
greatest superhero movie ever made
because it has fart jokes in it I don't
know if they're ready for something like
this and I don't know if Fincher can
handle the level of CG that's going to
be required of him he does great
beautiful
real-world cinematography in order to
achieve the visuals which are a big
selling point on that book
Moshiach is CG you're going to ask him
to step out of his comfort zone which
might not be something that estudia
would want to set their dollars behind I
think they'll do I think they put more
money behind David Fincher than Ryan
Coogler or David Cronenberg any day of
the week I think the primary antagonist
of both Arkham Asylum and the resid
storyline are both the Joker and maybe
Harley Quinn which again we've already
we've already had which by the way we're
talking about Jared Leto's Joker which
was not however we all feel it was not
very well received so we're talking
about more of that in in Arkham Asylum
and in the Red Hood and so it's more of
what we've seen done really well like
the ferry it's a really great movie and
now you're like let's compete with that
as opposed to doing something very
different something line up spills on
something that people already love they
don't want Jared Leto sure they love The
Dark Knight so why not make this
universe is dark night if you compare
and you like more than happiness or
weekend we've had a lot of like Red Hood
is just an anti Baron with guns which we
have the wrath we have hush we know whom
are in the cinematic universe and none
of them to be in the middle but they
might be better choices Superman is
fighting an alien we have thought who he
fought in the first movie that not many
people like all of his villains are
elgif mixi whose magic alien I also
argue again but then a lot of elements
from this arc that I'm choosing were you
doing justice to video game that's being
very well with any of minor from the
Arkham series which is a greatest
selling DC video game franchise of all
time
but then you see you're citing the
injustice video game is inspiration for
your movie and injustice is definitely
an r-rated video game and you're talking
about strategy yeah okay oh are you
coming that my girls know your knives
and just bit of a bit of a side trivia
that Dan can verify Brainiac was
actually the villain in Superman 3 and
they couldn't afford it so they made it
down in Richard Pryor not your prior
arrest was it when we already had that
fire ok again yeah I um
we got what is what I would give to us
that Brainiac doesn't matter it might be
Palin gene Wilder yeah Oh God it's just
anyway I can the Arkham Asylum is a
fantastic a graphic novel Grant Morrison
is one of the all-time greats the movie
you're pitching is not that though it is
not the reign of Batman
I am absolutely that is exactly what it
is there's lots of psychosis like the
psychology stuff in it with Batman and
the villains but the book is Batman is
trapped in Arkham Asylum and all his
villains are freed from their cages
that is what Arkham Asylum is and that
is that to me is a movie that's an easy
sell to people you get the best of all
Batman worlds because you put Batman and
Alice he doesn't have his gadgets he
doesn't have anyone helping him and he's
got his great rogues gallery the best
rogues gallery in all of superheroes and
maybe in all fictional fictional heroes
this twelve or thirteen villains yes
we've seen the Joker in poison ivy but
there are so many other villains that
are appear in Grant Morrison's book that
we've never seen before and the depth on
the bench of the villains in that movie
that alone you're going to get people to
see what excited I'm actually going to I
would say Arkham Asylum is tough because
Batman is not his villains and you're
trying to sell a movie on his villains
I'm trying to sell you a movie in a
pitch on Batman and his family and also
half of the characters that are set up
as important villains in Arkham are
currently benched for the Suicide Squad
and we're got this does the question
wasn't how does this fit in the DC
extended universe that's not the
question if that's not the argument I'm
that's argument I'm making you can you
can reject it it's fine we could be
friends of the error argument
djay nobody wants another Superman movie
where he fights aliens but again it's
not it's not fighting aliens not like
dog where it's a big match it's not like
dark side were it's a big country
mansion it allows you a super a
situation that Superman is rarely
allowed to where he has to think his way
to defeat an enemy that is supposed to
be one of the smartest things on the
planet and it allows you an opportunity
to really explore avenues in the
Superman mythos that we haven't seen
before which I think there's value in
that especially you need for getting
wonder when we're getting the flash we
want movies that push what a DC movie is
in new directions to find a director
right now define
in new and interesting ways and you want
something that brings interesting things
out of the character and so this is an
opportunity to explore against Superman
demand because he's facing something
that's not just another Kryptonian it's
not just a mindless monster it's
something that forces him to contend
with what needs to be on earth and to
consider himself part of humanity all
right Dan can you can you factor that
was Robert Zemeckis and Tom I heard that
Robert Rivera was taking meeting and it
haunted Rocklin I can't remember
competing but he's not in talks but he
is an extra zero matter today he said
rather about 9:00 to go she yes right oh
my god they all live together at Dennis
O'Neil gave an interview way back when
saying that he had heard that the one
900 Jason Todd line had been rigged by
somebody to four against it was very
close to vote but there's no evidence
and mark Superman three Ilya Salkind
originally wrote a treatment that
included Brainiac mr. Bicks afflict and
Gene Wilder's right yeah different than
we were talking about but apparently
Warner Brothers turned it down they
didn't like it so they were they use
some of the production art for that
pitch in the belly when a woman here and
pewter thing and there of course I've
always been fan series the rumors that
Richard Pryor's character Gus Gorman was
this Brainiac in some sense of the word
and so yeah there were there were shad
shades of Brainiac in Superman how about
Richard Pryor's mixa mixa little like
that was awesome yes in a purple suit
anything else
actually no all right this was tough
because I actually wouldn't mind seeing
all three B's to be perfectly honest
yeah I mean I think there was they came
down to two points I want to see that
man be a real detective and I don't want
to see more aliens I'm fine alien so I'm
those two stuck to most to me from
Ashley so Ashley gets the point
yeah thank you it does fit the best well
let the point where wasn't really the
question she did a good job of that was
actually key up
so very late marks in my video i watch
them off I watch them all too we're
fighting they're not enemy their time is
fun all right here we go around five
this is it last point you're already
into the seed round so congrats so mark
and Ashley you guys need a point to get
into the speed round against him here we
go this one comes from Stark s Adam on
twitter the question is of all the movie
Batman's which one would win in a fight
hitting the Batman against each other
who wins Ashley or first I am thinking
the Adam West Batman because the Adam
West Batman has a gadget for everything
we all know the joke about the shark
repellent bat spray you can think that's
silly it works he gets out of every jam
by being able to pull something out of
his pants and yes that means failing
having a gadget people dance at you
until you sleep with him he's got a
really nice manner so you're just going
to want to go and stay the night anyway
he has Robin and Batgirl who are very
capable per the rules of this universe
to back him up if he needs that and
failing that on Harriet would seduce
Keaton in minutes and fast luck would be
so taken aback he wouldn't even show up
to this fight Adam West was the first
Batman he's the silliest Batman which
means that he is the most off the rails
and he could do the craziest thing to
undermine anything that the other two
Batman could throw his way maybe even a
bomb so to clarify you're yeah you're
picking on West's Prime in the Batman 66
movie yeah yes okay the current animated
universe that's like okay yeah just make
sure we know which movie Batman you're
picking it great DJ bat flick I mean
he's literally twice the size of these
other Batman he's also like he's also
the most brutal Batman in movies he's
also gotten the best Batman fight scene
in any Batman movie ever whatever you
think about Batman V Superman that scene
at the end where he's kicking ass they
kick ass like it's great he would eat
the other Batman for breakfast hands
down all right mark I'm with Michael
Keaton because Michael Keaton's Batman
and Bruce Wayne are ours today I think
the best version of both of those
characters because you believe that
Michael Keaton is so scarred by the
death of his parents that instead of
enjoying being a multi-billionaire he
would spend all his money on doing this
crime-fighting thing there's a torment
to him in a fire in him that I don't see
in Christian Bale Christian Bale's
characters his Batman's is kind of a
thug who depends on everyone else around
him to make his gadgets Ben Affleck's
character is just so broody and so
midlife crisis
and just so angry that I think that that
his anger is what his engine I don't
think there's a lot of intelligence
there because he didn't figure out
things like the white portrait he's in
the movie he's not the smartest Batman
and technically Adam West isn't a movie
Batman he was a TV Batman first them and
they made a movie out of the TV show so
I don't know if that's splitting hairs
bad buddy if we're going to say that
their mental asylums wouldn't exist
because of the DC extended universe
technically he started out there were
two seasons when we get out before the
main date
so in count I just think that Michael
Keaton is the most the most fully
realized versions of both Batman and
Bruce Wayne I think that I believe that
he would have the intelligence I believe
that he's the most active participant in
being Batman of any of the Batman
alright now if I just have a play up the
fight for me how is it going to go down
okay so uh West has to do is get behind
either of these guys because they can't
turn their head neither of them can move
above the shoulder so if he gets behind
them and sneak attack anything again
he's got a fondness for bottom all the
ramifications I gotta say anything about
that family is going to bigger gut than
idea regular one four five yards and
fellow voting machine and we can team up
to take down back selects like I do is
say Martha and he's broken I wasn't that
was a very specific context context to
stay on or hate down if you if you saw
him taking down those twelve guys at the
end they on dad a mother in the same
name and if you've seen any of those
Batman without their shirt on
clearly ones doing the workouts to make
sure he's in peak condition so I
viewable there so there's talk that
there was some CG on him like there was
in the list of 300 guys when he's
learning turning over time tire unless
if Adam West seduces Kim Basinger onto
the set Michael Keaton as Bruce Wayne is
going to break right out of the Batman
persona because he pursues her so hard
he forgets to be Batman and he could
just take him out kick him to the knees
let's be honest that sucks not messing
around he took it he he murdered some
people in Batman V Superman and so he's
not pulling his punches and again we got
the brass knuckles on his gloves on but
he's overdone
brawler of these three Michael Keaton's
Batman is the smartest it would be using
detective skills and using his gadgets
and stuff it appears physical strength
yeah of course of course Ben Affleck is
physically stronger but he's just so
consumed by anger is going to punch it
there's no cleverness there's no mystery
there's no there's no thought process
you just want to beat the [ __ ] out of
something and that might work in an
enclosed space but as far as being able
to strategize Michael Keaton of these
three is the one that has must have to
do is let you two thugs go at each other
watch from above and again drop a bomb
drop a Robin drop a Batgirl drop a
Catwoman drop any of the rogues gallery
we've got the biggest Rosie I like pick
them up throw them over and you guys are
done can you give me one good fight
either of your Batman have been it all
of them you look like the victim how's
our iconic beyond measure like come on
you shouldn't even take on Green Hornet
and Kato man my age version independent
run that back major con so we can beat
them loosely wouldn't have to happen
family miles and then returns there's a
great fight at the very beginning when
he rescues Selina Kyle and eesh think
the clown's got the Taser to her and he
di shoots Batman shoots his on each
other any guys all you missed in bamas
like no he pulls with the law and knocks
the guy out he's thinking two steps
ahead of everyone else all Ben Affleck
does is like goes to Equinox and then
gets pissed and takes a protein shake
you pulled that wall onto Ben Affleck he
would shrug it off that means the
mountain and his costume can take
bullets I don't care what gadget you
throwing arrows Michael team's costume
they shoot him in the chest better look
in the head they fire like three rounds
like Adam West if I wasn't God's ability
this is to show some like key wisdom for
shooting I wasn't the luckiest man if
he's shot at if he's tripped up if he's
punched kicked thrown anything he always
has a nice pile of boxes to land then
some water or he falls right into the
Batmobile you cannot keep this guy down
he cannot be made but both of our Batman
at least have armor he's not even we're
not even wearing an athletic supporter
in that TV show so he's going to get
10,000
did you see how long it took him to
climb up the side of a building in those
shows like our Batman just winded going
to the ceremony after Robin because he's
the only one who cares about the members
of the bat family the only one who's not
let one of the sidekicks get murdered or
hurt almost so our Batman have the the
better vehicles like we both had bat
wings I would argue that flex is better
because it was able to fly on its own
alfred was able to fly it also every
December was exploring languages he has
engaged he had smoked bumps he has his
batarangs that are huge always often are
made for him and made for him by other
people Michael Keaton is an active
Batman in generating his own arsenal I
was Adam lat Michael Keaton was able to
literally rip off his own mask with his
bare hands and body makeup also came off
at the same time it's listen you're
attributing a lot of magic from your
universe you got this in the piles and
they're bringing in all those people
okay and Batman bat flick does not I'm
not saying he's the best Batman I'm just
saying in a fight he's of that way
overall he would win in an actual King
rada G Michael King tonight was alright
because it's a little all over the place
and I'm having trouble it's dependent on
your last two closings here is who would
win in a fight they're in a fight who's
going to win Lamy it out last time
Ashleigh white Adam West going to take
down app batfleck and keeping the fight
because I Hamas is kind of an old man
and nobody who has a good moral Center
as both of you are claiming is going to
hit an old man in the face
listen back quite clearly then what
happened so when they got him to face
what did he do he bombs them of course
okay listen the bats leg clearly does
not have the best moral Center he's
willing to fight dirty he's willing to
fight to the death and he is the of the
Batman on the table he's in peak
physical condition
he's also had the best on-screen fight
that yes also includes gadgets and he
was able to strategize and he has a
kick-ass vehicles with so many guns
we were talking about a fistfight well
you're talking about pin aside you're
getting your bomb
bestest fight on camera normally the
best Batman fistfight on camera once
again you're saying that you're mounted
that did the Adam West Batman wouldn't
injure people and though it hasn't lost
a sidekick as particularly this family
then you gonna use bombs on us so that's
kind of a little bit of cognitive
dissonance never using handy this is
classified man why can we fight
analogies and physically your Batman is
the strongest but once again in a fist
fight probably he's gonna win but just
on the force but he's so blinded by his
consumed by his rage that anyone that
has any moments of strategy or thinking
can outwit him because he is just he's
just consumed by that emotion and well
that's the physical strength is there
Michael Keaton's Batman is a Batman is
always thinking about the next steps and
always thinking about things so he would
be able to figure out a way to defeat
him using a brand Wow all right three
different three different things here I
need the couch to help me on this one
because this one is actually probably
the toughest one yet Dan no anything to
clean up before we make a decision
together actually no I was looking at
the back end and Robert or strawberry
Lancer and Kato fight from the 60s it
was a fight it was it under than what I
anticipated to be a bit of a draw
definitely why there was no clear Victor
but they were they were each giving as
well yeah Michael and Sammy what do you
think based on those arguments where are
you leaning I think Ashley has the most
creative but Ben Affleck is a badass and
he just takes things so I'm going to go
ahead go TJ dan what were you thinking
I don't know it's very hard to for me
it's between the DJ made a great point
about the kind of invulnerability and
drinks of this choice so many guns no
moral Center yeah Batman right
but I actually very creative with her
hide wagon very creative but it but for
me again it is it comes down to the
fight aspect for me it would be between
strength and strategy and so I actually
drank from strategy I think that I would
go towards strategy personally I
remember second bag I'm with the
strategy as well gotta have some brain
she gotta have it you can you can a duck
a duck hostess you can outsmart somebody
you can duck a pal mmm this is true only
in theory the PALS mean that you've made
contact
yeah you know what there you guys are
swimming too cuz I didn't hear anything
ever really combated wise how they could
take out the strategy of Michael Keaton
because yes you won't hit a man and you
pow me with the bombs and the guns but
you made the point that he'd be three
steps ahead of that so they probably
already blown up before it got that
point so I got to give mark the points I
messed up I should have brought up the
fact that he spends half that movie
preparing for a fight with Superman and
they will take advantage I turn it up I
screwed up forever man I am animated you
said you did the right to negative
energy to do it but I would have died
with a counter by saying why would you
make dust bombs instead of Krypton like
breast knuckle they're just but I read
all right but Ashley what a game Ashley
thank you for doing this you're still
you know you're gonna we're going to
help decide the winner here your help me
judge this last feed around here these
are benign DNA here we go guys will each
get twenty seconds and then 10-second
rebuttals you both have done this you
know how to do it let's get you a cue
the speed round music and here we go
number one who gives the best ever
performance as Bruce Wayne Michael
Keaton bad look interesting
okay it's the same argument but now
we're arguing about Bruce Wayne we're
different not Batman alright mark I
heard you first Michael Keaton Michael
Keaton plays the torment of a guy who
suffer deeply impactful losses of
childhood and feel extreme guilt about
that he also plays a guy who's juggling
these these things with all the aspects
of his life which have wanting to have a
relationship if not wanted to bring a
woman into his life for fear that they
will be injured the whole scene the
scene alone in Batman Returns with him
and Michael were with him and Michelle
Pfeiffer dancing and she says don't we
have to fight now is more emotionally
dead than anything DJ Mag not only it
doesn't he doesn't just have the rage he
doesn't just have the torment but when
he's flirting with a woman that's you
can tell this not just an act like that
team really enjoying the Bruce Wayne
aspect like I see Ben Affleck and I see
a billionaire play forever arguing the
best Bruce Wayne that's the first time
where I really bought into the
billionaire playboy aspect of the
character mark 10 seconds when you're I
think yeah I know
I didn't think Batman I don't think that
ass like Bruce Wayne enjoyed anything in
that movie except blowing things up and
fighting Batman Michael King gets laid a
lot of his Batman movies he enjoys the
playboy aspect of it he had a sweet
collar with like nice shoes and
everything and also he's he portrays the
physicality and it's a layered
performance so he's got the rage you've
got the flirtatious as you got the drive
alright actually based on their argument
where do you thinking I'm thinking that
slay what did you hear from DJ let's
wager I like the fact that he did
mention the rage and some of the things
that he's been criticized on but that on
top of that we layer in the personal
side and the seduction guys in the cows
what do you think going Michael Keaton
on this one
yeah going against the grain Danna
playing along in my head as I often do
I'll set out here I was thinking that I
would have picked George Clooney because
I thought personally I would argue that
he did the best of portraying Bruce
Wayne the mask the character and I feel
like DJ articulated that really well and
is there even on Bruce Wayne is he's not
just the rage of the torment he's also
the persona of Bruce Wayne and so I'm
gonna side with DJ yeah that's that was
tough but I'm gonna I because I'm on the
fence I'm gonna let the we didn't have
her yet the majority rule that's a good
argument that's a good argument there
you go so you're out mark so you didn't
matter what I said yeah majority rules
DJ gets the first point all right here
we go
next Superman movie Superman to Superman
all right
you both had time there to think about
it Superman mark may you sense of my
chairmanship soup to mark your first
Superman one is groundbreaking but
Superman once suffered from the fact of
making Lex Luthor a buffoon and there
was some there was never a legitimate
real threat in the movie the Superman
district went to opened up and brought
Superman's face to face with villains
who are in the same race who here has
been equal to physically and it also
expanded upon this to Clark Kent Lois
Lane Superman triangle he reveals his
identity to her there was so much human
stuff but we really build a relationship
isn't Superman one that's what
introduced a majority the world to as a
character and create meet our most
iconic serum which is Christopher Reeve
and we got that great origin story which
is what made every super movie sense
them think they need to be an origin
story didn't use almost time Wow small D
10 seconds I think the Superman one is a
great movie but I think Superman too
expands the mythology and expands the
world as the use of the cosmic villains
and Superman to show that we could go
and not make these movies low-budget
sci-fi trash they wore in the 50s and
make big
but that started with Superman won and
the idea of taking that seriously and
also had the balls to kill off Lois Lane
at the end which yeah I went back but
obviously our audiences were shocked by
that and so we I did a lot of different
things
all right yeah keep your mouth shut
there mark come on and typically just
using it's technically that's true
Truman wanted to better you know
basement arguments actually what do you
think I'm always really explained by the
one that did it first I gotta go
Superman Dan I actually was kind of a
swayed by marks arguments of one is
groundbreaking but to unbanded it and
yeah he was up against villains of its
own type so I actually would to go for
me thank you you too how does it go
Superman because they killed off Lois my
enough of those a yeah and then punch
yeah I like the cosmic myths of opening
up the world kneel before Zod
I know yeah I got it I'm going to go
with mark on that one I'm going to
tighten that up this is we're tied here
we go now keeping in mind they can't use
their powers or gadgets or resources
clear what DC character would you want
to be stuck in an elevator with for
several hours Superman they can't use
their power can't use their power
gadgets a resources which here are gonna
be stuck in the elevator with Batman
okay let's hear why deejay Superman is a
regular guy you can talk to him out with
things else alone form because he's a
reporter he's also has a super fast
alien mind and is filled with
information from all his adventures
across the world you'd have endless
stories to spend your time in that
elevator with and you could get some
really he's got you have great
relationships you get great relationship
advice from them embark well I have no
desire to spend hours upon hours in an
elevator with anyone unless it's Henry
Cavill Superman but you didn't say that
but like the Batman would be able to
figure out a way to get out of there cuz
Batman is actual real world mechanical
applications and life experience where a
Superman about his powers we see what
happens when he gets that doesn't have
his powers he gets punched in the face
meant and in that diner in super into
and passes out when he sees his own
blood even if you took away the powers
in the super fast mind he's still a
well-read reporter so a fantastic writer
he still had a me
experiences that he could share with you
and you still do like I can't imagine
having a conversation with Batman it's
not a conversation that's how do we get
out of this goddamn elevator the
quickest do you want to spend hours in
an elevator
Superman yeah all right
I think market look fully answer the
question right he got stuck on Batman's
we have no gadgets he would take
questions you're going to be stuck in
the elevator with only that you want to
get out of the elevator well I mean yes
forum but that wasn't the question so
I'm leaning there a DJ stunt but unless
you guys can sway me what do you think
Ashley Mason there I can't believe that
neither of you just picked someone you
wanted to make out with it is not coming
you didn't think with I actually mired
you it would have been very similar
marks because I would have picked Robin
for that same reason as we've seen him
break in and out of elevators between
Batman break in and out of elevators I
got to go to mark all right I've been
stuck dan what do you guys say I would
have gone with DJ I think you brought up
initiative thing is like Superman's
breadth of experience yeah what am I
going to get a chance to talk to someone
that's been to another planet before all
that relation yeah I'm going with women
no III know Lauren his adventures that
man is just going to tell me about how
depressed he is he's going to trying out
of the elevator is durable we'll have a
question he's not going to be able to I
mean frustrating I would go with you
Jake what do you guys thank you agree
yeah I would love to hear the Superman
stories all right DJ you get it
swimming stories for the win all right
Lana Lang and a mermaid you got it all
right here we go I wish aside from
Deadshot and Harley Quinn who is the
best member of Suicide Squad Amanda
Waller I have an asterisk for that is
that the we're talking like a movie yes
okay discussion it's right here guys and
I was just reading this I would say
katana oh okay okay great I will hide my
sorry I mean to show my cards there I'm
open to the argument okay katana Amanda
Waller will accept Amanda Waller she's
technically part of the squad right
she's the boss the head of the
accounts right it's us you you're just
good she owns the franchise I mean
there's been the group shot dreaming
I'll pick another oh yeah me III don't
want the commenters to flip out Dan what
do you think Mikey we think yeah he's
got an argument so he clearly wants to
say something all right all right good
try it
goat started me yeah a listen Amanda
what you're you have a movie filled with
murderers and monsters and Waller is
easily the scariest person in that movie
she she is the one that's able to rein
in these people bring them in she's the
one with a plan she's also the person
that will stand up to Batman and talk
him down and make him look like a wuss
and that doesn't matter in the movie she
does it and every other incarnation she
does it Marc
katana has the least dialogue in the
suicide so everybody told us she has the
least bad dialogue in the movie she is a
presence with her silence and her powers
and she has the best weapon her sword
will take your soul so she is arguably
the most powerful member more than me a
chant rest' in that group all right CJ
I'm Viola Davis is amazing in that movie
she really sells the weight of it and
she's the one in charge and she's the
one that all those scary people will
cower down to seconds katana is a loyal
warrior who is as it has an emotional
connection to what she's doing Amanda
Waller's plan in the movie is to create
a squad because she had Lisa V
enchantress to rescue her but if she
never at least said would have happened
she's not very good leader that's true
Ashley what do you think based on
arguments I like what those character
and I like both those actors but I gotta
go katana I thought marks and maids it's
really interesting points I'll see I
didn't die I was fight so you were
starting going a joky like because they
literally going joking occasionally and
I wish it was kept going joke II could
said look the missus katana she's got my
back I would not advise being killed by
her her sword Trump's the souls of its
victims if you had it Hamed in on that I
would have been soaking yeah I don't
know - what do you guys think I would go
with katana really based on why what's
based on March 4th wall breaking
argument of lys dialogue in the movie
but also I felt like
it was just that Amanda Waller was mean
and Marx was like she's loyal she she
you know she's gonna have your she is
going to have your back you see we go
back
so I actually pick mark played a better
car why does head a it's true she's got
her back mark you're on it still here we
goes and the last question so excited
for we are tied my back up would have
been El Diablo let's see let's all right
best Joel Schumacher directed Batman
villain Oh Riddler Frigg look for he's
an IV okay ice to see know and pigment I
didn't believe you are gave them awesome
alright DJ for the win here Riddler and
then marks poison ivy go ahead when you
ready Riddler fits the tone of that
movie better than any of the other Joel
Schumacher villains he really embraces
the king of that it was smart enough to
channel in Frank Gorshin who's the
character the the person that made
Riddler famous to begin with so he not
only provides an iconic take he's it one
thing that you would remember out that
movie and love mark
hua Thurman is playing poison ivy as a
seductress and playing it as a forty
sort of vamp and embracing the sort of
embracing the Schumacher sensibility and
is one of the few things in Batman Robin
that works because she gets the joke
she's playing Mae West as a seductress
and as a villain and is the only one
that seems to have read the script and
figured out what kind of movie they were
actually making including the director
she's the one thing that rings true in
that movie I want to hear you each
attack the other one in its closing
because good strong openers but I have a
very memorable I remember Jim Carrey's
Riddler very well I don't remember
anything Zimmerman did in that movie I
had argue how great it was and so you
know I loved it and if nobody she I
think every other villain got crushed by
the Joel Schumacher machine in religion
Jim Carrey in that movie is so
frustrating it's every quirk he's ever
done in one ugly package and only thing
I remember about him and that movie
really is that awful rhinestone costume
yet at the end which is too gay for even
me
[Music]
Wow all right Ashley based on the
arguments what do you think I think CJ
did a really good job explaining the
depths that I don't believe actually
exist in that character good point
let's go to the couch Michael what do
you think I I would have gone Riddler
but I feel like Marc made better
argument so what was about the argument
that he let me let me collect my
thoughts
Sam it's hard right yeah they both need
the same opening arguments that both of
these characters knew which movie they
were at and I think that's kind of what
they both have to be getting so yeah I'm
glad that she kind of has them attack so
it's really who had the who has a
stronger attack on the other guest and I
feel like like Marc maybe had a stronger
hit back at DJ so I think I would go
with Marc but very close Sammy
chime in I don't have to get his mark on
this one I agree I think he had the
stronger attack back and I agree with
the character she's more mysterious she
took ownership of her role and you can
you can do more things with her than the
Riddler because people kind of can buy
in to her seductiveness in her her
mysteriousness
yeah she was a vamp she knew a movie but
you vote at a point in passage right DJ
make me think more than he was there but
yeah that's a fair point of attack back
was stronger from Marc I think that's
the slight edge to give multiple in the
winning
[Applause]
you guys were both whoa I want to give
you birth login ugly oh yeah
we put background to mark a drag mark
and Dre code on Twitter what else you
got going on you unplug Batman 66 Wonder
Woman 77 is ramping up the last issue
and then the hardcover collection will
be out in Jill LA in August and love is
love has broken the $200,000 mark of
donated and we're doing seven foreign
editions that will give money to local
charities in different countries around
the world it still available on
amazon.com in your local comic book
store I love it Ashley Robbins Ashley V
Robinson on Twitter what do you like to
plug here also love is love because I
have a page in it and it's for an
amazing cause goes into the geek history
lesson podcast II kissed your lesson
comment pre-order my creator own comic
book series at Jupiter jet backer kit
comm love it go support and DJ Woolrich
at DJ talks trash computer also a little
bow just because it's dope and also you
check out my podcast only stupid answers
with Sam basher everywhere podcasts are
listened to all night everywhere huh now
and we will all be doing an audio
version of Suicide Squad movie
novelization don't worry I like that hi
Dan Majerle Merle Dan Dan's labyrinth
every Monday as I say yet we're be
talking Wonder Woman on Monday we'll see
how those box office numbers come in I
think it's gonna be pretty we'll see
maybe we'll see not agree Michael and
Sammy thank you for coming hope you had
fun we had a blast I had a blast you
guys are great to watch your read
Kentucky let me know well give you a
tour around yeah yeah done and thank you
all home for watching we'll see you next
week with the semi this is the
championship finals yeah the winner of
this will go on to face mr. madman Merle
over there JT movie man and Mike Carlson
down yeah fight watch it next week I
have no idea that's me go die watch
little clue with and then Dan Murr we'll
be back in the ring soon to take it on
and put that belt up on the line I can't
wait I can't either I've been want to
put the spell to pay a lot of time it's
got to lay down we wanted
but it'll be worth the wait and then
will you'll be back in the running to
keep plating I love it alright that's it
thanks for watching whatever wonderful
week and we'll see you next time bye bye
my